LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today, we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
with a Googler."
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And I'm here today
chatting with Sunil, who's
from our Voice Actions team.
And he's going to be talking
a lot about Voice Actions
and how they work in Android
and some of the great things
that you can do as a
developer with them.
So welcome, Sunil.
And thanks, for joining us.
SUNIL VEMURI: Thanks,
for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So tell
us all about what you do.
SUNIL VEMURI: So I am a product
manager on the Voice Actions
team.
And the main thing
that I do is enable
Voice Actions for developers.
But let me first say,
what is a voice action?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
can we have a demo?
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
SUNIL VEMURI: This
is the part in Google
where you can say, OK Google.
Navigate to San Francisco.
ELECTRONIC VOICE:
Navigating to San Francisco.
SUNIL VEMURI: And then--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SUNIL VEMURI: --you can
get directions and things
like that.
But there are other
things you can
do, like I can say, call
Laurence or start my run.
All of these things are
various voice actions
that Google supports right now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Nice.
Now I know you've done
a DevByte recently
explaining some of this, right?
SUNIL VEMURI: Yes, we have.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Let's run a clip from
that DevByte now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I love listening to
the radio on my commute.
And the TuneIn app
gives me great choices.
OK Google.
Play music on TuneIn.
-Which genre would
you like to listen to?
-Classical.
-Playing classical.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Pretty neat stuff.
SUNIL VEMURI: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, one
of the things I've always
been curious about was-- because
I remember in the past, when
I've been doing voice
interaction stuff,
I used to have to
train the machine.
And I'd sit with a
microphone close my mouth,
and I'd read weird
sentences, so it
could understand all
the different things
that I was saying.
But now, I can just pick up
my phone and say, OK Google,
navigate to San Francisco.
What's happened?
How has that come about?
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
That's been a really awesome
progress in the speech field.
What really has changed is the
amount of data that we've had.
So in the early days, when we
only had a little bit of data,
it only worked for
a few circumstances.
But later on, as we
got more and more data,
it got better and
better and better.
So take, for example, in 2013,
we had about a 23% word error
rate.
And that's how we measure
the quality of speech.
So 23% of the words were wrong.
And that's not very good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
SUNIL VEMURI: At I/O,
we recently announced
it's down to 8%.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
SUNIL VEMURI: And that
makes a big difference,
especially when you're talking
about applications like this.
And in many ways, it has shown
that voice is really possible
and is a viable candidate for
a lot of different interactions
right now, because the
error rates have gotten down
so significantly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And even like earlier,
you said, San Francisco,
which are technically
Spanish words, right?
But it recognized
them as the place.
And I thought that
was really cool.
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
I mean, there's a
lot of treatment that
goes into it that
tries to understand,
what is the actual right
interpretation of this sentence
in this context, as well?
So that's a lot of the work
that goes on in this team that's
helped to really make it a
better experience for users
and now developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
And I have a foreign accent,
and it recognizes me.
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right?
And it's like, how
is it that you're
able to come up with--
to be able to recognize
different voices, not
just the classic monotone,
straight English
voice type of thing?
What type of work has
been done for that?
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
You know, back in
the early days,
you had to be a white male
between the ages of 25 and 40
for this thing to work.
And you had to be
in a quiet room.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: So
what really changed
is we started to include a much
more diverse set of samples
in here, so a broader
set of accents, a broader
set of speakers, older,
younger speakers.
Even nowadays, it
works really well
with children, which has long
since been a difficult problem.
So as we included more
and more of these samples
and a diverse set, it
created this virtual cycle
where more people
started to use it.
And we can improve
the system with that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Cool.
Now developers-- we have
a DevByte that we just
showed a moment ago--
now, how do developers
get started with doing this?
What kind of things can they do?
SUNIL VEMURI: So believe it
or not, a lot of developers
are already voice-enabled.
And the way this has happened
is we've leveraged the Android
intent system here.
So first thing we do is
we analyze or we look at,
what did the user say?
And if they say a
number of things
that we already recognize,
like start a run, set an alarm,
play some music,
Google has already
developed the language to
recognize these things,
and we fire an intent.
Now, lots of
applications out there
already support these intents.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: So we're
already firing these things
to these applications that
support these intents.
So many applications
are already supported.
And this is what we
call system actions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: Google
recognizes the language
and fires an intent
over to an application.
And then the
application is the one
that can give the
response to the user.
And this, in many ways, is
how we are driving traffic
to applications.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, nice.
OK.
Now, the system
intent-- system actions.
Sorry.
There's other types of actions?
SUNIL VEMURI: Yeah.
So Google has created
a bunch of these things
to handle the common
situations that we
see users use on phones,
watches, and other devices.
But what if it's something
that Google hasn't created?
That's where we
introduce custom actions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: This is where
a developer can tell us
the language that they would
like us to trigger on and then
send to their applications.
Take, for example,
turn on the lights.
We don't do that right now.
Or Shazam, this song.
This isn't something that
we would build by ourselves.
But developers have asked
us for grammars like this.
And then, when they do
that, we trigger the intent
that they asked for
for their application.
So the custom actions
APIs are the ones that
allow developers to do this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Cool.
Now, there's also the ability
to interact over voice, right?
So follow up questions,
that type of thing.
SUNIL VEMURI: Yes, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
How does that work?
SUNIL VEMURI: So
we talked about two
of these things,
system and custom.
And this has to do
with triggering.
Now, just imagine you're
on the Google home screen,
and you say, OK Google,
turn on the lights,
or whatever it might be.
But let's take that
one query for example.
That can be ambiguous.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
SUNIL VEMURI: Because the
home automation application
might wonder, what lights?
Which room?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: Or if I
said, unlock the door,
it might want to
say, are you sure?
Because I wouldn't want you
to unlock my door, would I?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
SUNIL VEMURI: Well, no.
You seem like a nice guy.
But, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Appearances can be deceptive.
SUNIL VEMURI: They can.
[LAUGHTER]
So what we have is another API,
called Voice Interaction API.
And this is a new
API in Android M that
allows for the follow-on
questions that are very
typical in a voice dialogue.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: So
in this case here,
a developer would still
implement the custom action
to do something like
turn on the lights.
But in their
application, they would
ask the follow-up question.
And what happens here is,
at the bottom of the screen,
we will maintain all
the challenge and UI
for a voice interaction.
And at the top of the screen
is the developer's UI.
So we split the screen
with the developer.
So the developer only needs
to care about the question
and what are the
possible answers.
We'll take care of
all the challenges
that go along with
voice, including
managing the microphone,
what if the user didn't say
exactly what was on the list.
All of these things are
Google's responsibility.
So we've made it much
simpler for a developer
to implement these types
of voice interactions.
And for voice, it's
particularly important,
because there's
always ambiguity,
and there's always
a lack of clarity.
Well, I shouldn't say
always, but there's often
lack of clarity.
And we want to give
developers the chance
to build very interesting
and neat applications,
by dialoguing with their users.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So help
me to understand that.
So if I did something like,
OK Google, turn on the lights,
and so then this API
would say, do you
want the bedroom
lights turned on?
Or do you want the
kitchen lights turned on?
That type of thing?
SUNIL VEMURI: Well, it's
the application developer
who would ask that question.
They know what's the best
way to respond to that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: So I mean, in a
home automation application,
you might label your lights
as Laurence's Lights,
or Laurence's Office,
or something like that.
So that's where the application
can ask the question,
which room would you like?
Or it could say
something like, would you
like Laurence's Office?
Or Laurence's Room?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
Got it.
SUNIL VEMURI: It's totally
up to the developer.
You know, we want
the developer to have
the control of that dialogue,
to ask the questions that
make sense for them,
and also put up
the nice UI that they might want
to put up with that, as well.
Like they might
have an animation
or a beautiful display of
different rooms on the screen.
You know, we really
want our developers
to unleash their
imagination with this.
And so that's why we wanted
to take the burden of handling
the voice, and let them put
their creativity on the device
at the same time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
are there any examples
of this that are out there
that are working right now?
SUNIL VEMURI: So right now,
at I/O, we showed the TuneIn
to an implementation like this.
So they did the following.
OK Google, play some
music on TuneIn.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SUNIL VEMURI: And
then what TuneIn
would ask is, what genre?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
SUNIL VEMURI: Because
the music wasn't clear,
or what kind of
music wasn't clear.
So they ask, which genre?
They present a list of
the TuneIn channels.
User can select that,
and then the music plays.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SUNIL VEMURI: So
that's one example
that we've already seen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
SUNIL VEMURI: And we
have more coming, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And I assume the conversation
can take multiple steps, right?
It's not just a single question.
There can be further
clarifying ones?
SUNIL VEMURI: Absolutely.
And we're looking
forward to the day
when we can order a
pizza with this thing,
with toppings, and sizes,
and things like that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I'm sure it's not too far off.
SUNIL VEMURI: I hope so.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So thanks, Sunil.
That was awesome.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee With a Googler."
If you're interested in more
about the Voice Interactions
API and all the kind
of things that you
can do with Voice
Interaction on Android,
check out the links
underneath the video
here in the description.
And if you have any
questions for me
or any questions for
Sunil, just leave them
in the comments below.
Thank you.